my moment was the headline of the New
York Times after I guess it was the
first or second Republican debate where
Trump had gone on CNN and talked about
how megyn kelly was bleeding after eyes
first whatever okay thanks first and I
and I thought okay well whatever but it
was the top headline at the top of the
New York Times that is so strange why is
that
to humiliate Trump to some degree this
was just something that you could you
could kind of you know talk about
minimally but to create an entire
narrative over this in order to
humiliate him her to get him canceled
was the beginning for me of like oh
there's something else going on as a
secret history year
[Music]
you mentioned cancel culture before and
then I brought up the the charges of
misogyny related to American Psycho
yeah so I just read on your Wikipedia
and if it's on Wikipedia it's got to be
true that you had the deal for American
Psycho with Simon & Schuster but then
because what was it women of now or the
now of women or the something they
accused you of being misogynistic like
then and then was the book dropped I
mean this is sort of an early version of
cancel : oh it is it was I had that
story up for me I got a big deal at
Simon Chester I turn the book in this is
a long time ago in December of 1989 and
throughout 1990 the book kind of moved
through the usual ones of the latter
that it does through a publishing house
getting copy edited we figure out a
cover you're at you're editor does some
basic editing on it but there were
people in the publishing house were very
offended by American Psycho usually
assistants young people working in in
the in the publishing house and leaks
started happening leaks of some of the
most violent passages were being sent to
the press and certain members of the
press and so suddenly it became a story
and the book hadn't been published yet
but it became a story and it became more
and more controversial the more and more
that these notorious scenes were leaked
and of course out of there horrible and
so anyway the controversy got louder and
louder and louder and yes kind of like
today in a way Simon & Schuster
collapsed and said we are not going to
publish this book because of the outcry
in the media now this is another thing
that happened then is that it was
actually the corporation that owned
Simon Schuster that demanded the
cancellation it was Gulf and Western who
owned Simon & Schuster and the head of
Gulf and Western did not like the
controversy did not like the fact that
his his corporation was being blemished
by this book who ordered the
cancellation I knew the head of that
company of Simon Shuster quite well and
I knew that he wasn't the one who
cancelled it but he was
fall guy mmm you got to take it so
anyway that is what happened it's a
happy ending because a better publisher
picked up American Psycho and they
published it a few months later and you
know the rest is whatever it is right so
we're definitely and happily and a
movies made everybody say one thing
that's very interesting is that Tammy
Bruce was the head of now who was the
most against American Psycho she was my
nemesis then in 1991 and now that's
hilarious and you know she's on she's
one of the leading lights the bright
lights and Fox actually and so I I don't
know I find that kind of ironic in the
way that the culture works I mean that
fits so much of a lot of stuff that
we've talked about privately because the
one I've only met Tammy Bruce once it
was at david horowitz freedom center
thinking david horowitz was a famous
lefty children of communist who then you
know became became you know conservative
and with his conference he did a thing
on sort of the new generation of former
lefties that have sort of woken up and
it was me tammy bruce candace owens and
a couple other people's that's the only
time i met her and it's funny she was
opposed to you back then and that's
actually a great segue for a little
political stuff where are you
politically i mean i have a sense of
kind of where you're at and and
everything these days feels sort of
amorphous but you know what I was ever
political person
I just wasn't maybe it was because I was
privileged to a degree and politics just
didn't interest me why would they I was
a privileged white kid and moving from
high school into college during the
Reagan 80s everything seemed whatever I
mean I got I guess I complain about
Reagan mindlessly like all of my other
kids of my class and a lot of people
took American Psycho to be a book that
was critical of aliens of the Reagan
eighties and it was critical of some of
the cultural values certainly about
greed and about yuppie them but I'd end
up beef with Ronald Reagan I mean that
wasn't part of what that book was about
some of his iconic iconic iconography is
used in the book but you know that was
just he was just the president during
the time that that book took place and
then you know I was living with someone
for a long time who was very invested in
politics actually ran a couple of
gubernatorial campaigns
in the 90s and I got a close-up look to
that and I just hated it I just hated
the whole notion of how it was all
played out and none of it interested me
and it really and I I during the Obama
era did everything's fine I mean I
wasn't really paying attention something
happened with Trump something happened
with Trump that I think has happened to
all of us
to one degree or another something was
announced and I again another
presidential election cycles coming up
and I'm kind of following it but
suddenly I'm following it because it's
very interesting to me how the media is
treating the Donald Trump narrative now
I'm talking about a media that I had
been following closely for 30 years and
trusted someone the New York Times CNN
New York Times and CNN all of my life I
read them and I trusted them and I
believed in them and it was all they
were you know and I began to think that
they were missing the story that they
were going off a different path that
really wasn't the reality that wasn't
the reality that there was a new
narrative that they were forming and
this began to bother me and I don't know
why I hear yeah
I don't know why I am I'm nonpartisan I
never saw myself as I never saw myself
really if I saw much I think we have a
similar trajectory I think that I was a
liberal guy who was gay and was you know
rightly so rightly so it was fine
not never stridently never far left or
whatever but I you know I believed in
the good fight on the liberal side
something happened I began to see that
this sign was curdling yeah do December
do you remember a moment cuz a lot of I
do a lot of people have like V moments
yeah what was my my moment was the
headline of the New York Times after I
guess it was the first or second
Republican debate where Trump had gone
on CNN and talked about how megyn kelly
was bleeding got the wrong first
whatever okay thanks first and I and I
thought okay well whatever but it was
the top headline at the top of the New
York Times that is so strange why is
that
to humiliate Trump to some degree this
was just something that you could you
could kind of you know talk about Miz
Moli but to create an entire narrative
over this in order to humiliate him or
to get him canceled was the beginning
for me of like oh there's something else
going on as a secret history year and
that is how I began to become somewhat
radicalized in a way from who I thought
I was to where I ended up being and
again I have to say I'm not a partisan I
I still am someone who is loath to vote
I'm in the majority of this country and
yet what I've noticed you mean you
didn't go to my dumping my dumpy polling
station over here where I'm pretty sure
I could practically you were there
yesterday no I was there and I'm not
going to be there but I so but I what I
found so interesting and really what
white a lot of it is about is about how
I saw the left begin to disintegrate and
a part of the aisle that I thought I was
on I was I thought it was in that part
that side of the theatre and I realized
that I'm not and I don't want to be on
this side of the theatre if it is this
hysterical this crazed and it's and also
I really hated the creation of
narratives that were obviously not true
that were being used to undermine a
legally elected president whether I
liked him or didn't like him I just
thought there was something so
distinctly an American about the way the
left was creating their stories that it
just began to unnerve me yeah you know
it's super interesting about that that
David Horowitz who we just mentioned
when I had him in here he's a huge Trump
supporter and I asked him do you have a
moment when that happened and he
mentioned the megyn kelly bleeding line
because he said for him as someone that
had was a conservative but was love but
didn't understand the Trump thing he's
like that moment got it for him because
because it was basically Trump being
like screw all of you I play by none of
your rules so that same moment that sort
of had you wake up from a media
perspective as a lefty for him as a
conservative was like that was why he
loved Trump but it's so weird because
yes the Trump screw all the rules guy is
what everyone loves
that's what everybody loves yeah and
it's so interesting that yet on the
other side is what a lot of people are
horrified by who would normally like
that supposed to be any person right and
yet because it's Trump and this is the
problem with Trump and I talked about
this again in the book it is about I
believe it's about anesthetic it's about
this guy and what he looks like and I
always have said that if Trump was in
the package of a Mitt Romney it might be
more palatable for a lot of people and
we certainly would not have this kind of
like with what is truly I believe Trump
derangement syndrome if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell